federal judge in texas ruling in favor  to end the deferred action for childhood  arrivals program also known as daca  right now the program protects 650 000  people  now those already enrolled will keep  those protections  however the ruling will stop any new  approvals  governor sisilak responding to the  ruling tweeting quote today's ruling  against the daca program is devastating  news for nevada and more than 21  thousand daca eligible individuals who  call nevada home  in the nine years daca has been in place  it has provided  a lifeline for thousands of young  immigrants to live and contribute to  this country  the lives and futures of our dreamers  have been in limbo for far too long  and it is time we deliver a path to  citizenship to them and to the other  immigrants who have long contributed to  our communities